and speaking of lies
you can't really talk about lies these
days without talking about arizona right
that ballot audit that actually over the
weekend reports came out said hey it's
drawing to a close
so you know that'll be fun i wonder if
that'll be
you know coincide maybe with mike
lindell's
grand cyber symposium this week but
either way
an even bigger story came out this past
weekend about the arizona
audit and this one is truly disgusting
and it also is representative of what
we've seen happen to officials all over
the country
since the 2020 election
a republican member of maricopa county's
board of supervisors
a man by the name of bill gates no not
that bill gates
but i'm sure that doesn't help with
republicans he spoke with cnn
over the weekend then he said this
unfortunately
the threats continue and they're not
simply organic
they're being driven unfortunately by
members of the arizona state senate and
other republicans across the country
we receive phone calls into our offices
at the board of supervisors
our staff you know saying that our
families are going to be slaughtered
and threatening us to stop standing up
for the good elections workers
of maricopa county
so any republican that dares to question
the narrative of a stolen election in
arizona
any of them who dare defend the
integrity of that
election in arizona are getting death
threats
we have actually seen this happening in
arizona
since i guess really since the audit
started
and there was actually videos of the
angry mob of trumpsters
you know that came in there and wanted
to get through and they
weren't allowed to be in there because
it was a ballot audit but
we've seen those videos georgia election
officials
mentioned earlier this year they were
getting death threats
even raffensberger and his wife you know
the republican secretary of state and
his wife
said they were getting death threats
it's happened in pennsylvania the death
threats are coming from these
crazed trump cultists
who genuinely believe that this election
was stolen
so anybody who comes out and says the
opposite must be the enemy
there must be somebody to be destroyed
and that is what they're threatening
here folks that that's that's where
we've landed that's where we've gotten
and it's sickening and it's disgusting
and unfortunately the lies that are
causing people to get this worked up
are not ending if anything they're
getting worse
and there has to come a day of reckoning
all of the abuse that these individuals
are suffering all of the death threats
that they are getting
something eventually has to happen to
the individuals getting people this
worked up
to to trump himself to to mike lindell
to sydney powell and lynn wood there has
to be accountability
for rudy giuliani for anyone else out
there spreading these lies
accountability has to happen because
people's lives are at stake now
and they're at stake because of the lies
being pushed
by these deranged individuals who refuse
to accept the obvious and that is
the public rejected donald trump
thank you for sitting here with me today
it's been an honor filling in for david
pakman these uh past two days i will be
back for two more days next week
in the meantime you can find me on
youtube youtube.com
fairbalance youtube.comfire twitter
facebook instagram
at fair and balance stay tuned for the
bonus show got some great stuff coming
up there for the members
have a great day